this season Eddie's heart we were under
construction when you're under
construction things happen water leaks
happen something so we were dealing we
thought sink broke in half and then the
guinea pig died the same day I broke my
foot in Mexico and our dog gets cancer
so it was just a whole lot of stuff
coming in at one at one time Tamra judge
isn't afraid to keep the real in Real
Housewives laying it all out there on
the new season of Real Housewives of
Orange County I'm just still trying to
process it
my husband's 45 years old in these heart
surgery
just God please make him okay the stuff
you were going through this year was a
lot of Eddie stuff still it yeah what's
the held updated well he's still the
same he's has now six heart procedures
two invasive heart procedures which
would be the ablation where they go in
through the growing and through the neck
and they like kind of cauterized the
parts of the heart that are not beating
properly and where the problem areas are
and then you know you have to stay on
medication then you have to wait three
months to see if it worked so it's a
process and then in between that stay
shocked his heart every few weeks when
he goes in because basically what it is
is you just ran a marathon but you
didn't you just woke up from bed so it's
like you wake up and he's like you know
and he's in persistent so it's not
something that comes and goes he's in it
all the time you know and then he'll be
sitting on the couch sometimes and he'll
be like and I'm like this is the big one
like what do I need to call like I
freaked out and he's like my heart's
freaking out I don't know and he'll just
literally lay on the ground or something
and he'll just take deep breaths I mean
this is my 46 year old husband like I'm
like what it that he's bit he's like
what is going on protect your heart
I just keep I just keep the mortality
rate that's like what is there a light
at the end of the tunnel or is it just
kind of in it we hope so you know we're
now on doctor three and we're doing
everything we can it could take up to
four blasians and I'm like you know what
do you really want to go in and fry your
heart every three months yeah like this
just doesn't sound good really starting
to get scared like I'm like is this your
life now yeah and we just don't know has
this tested your relationship at all or
made it stronger um it's made that we're
good like we've always been good I've
never seen him like this he's always
been super upbeat and now he's you know
he's even in middle like he's he gets a
little depressed sometimes because no he
wants to go you know do a Spartan Race
or even work out or ride his bike like
he would ride his bike three or four
days a week now he can and he's been do
not for years it was in high school it's
a big lifestyle change yeah so it's no I
mean we're good he gets a little grumpy
sometimes and I just know like to just
let him be
well it's kind of a testament to how
strong your relationship is yeah it's
like if something we're gonna break it
could be something like yeah no I'm not
gonna break now
[Music]